[Applause]
the rallies united brazilians from all
ages and walks of life
trade union leaders and left-wing
politicians standing side by side with
businessmen bankers and students
we have created a great front if we want
to defend brazil's democracy from
president gerbal sonora's attacks
this is a unique moment when businessmen
and workers join efforts to defend
democracy the main rally was at the
university of sao paulo's law school
where a similar event was held 45 years
ago against brazil's military
dictatorship
crowds gathered inside the building and
in the courtyard to listen to two
manifestos both defending brazil's
democratic institutions less than two
months before october's presidential
elections
our democracy is facing immense danger
our institutions are at risk from
insinuations and contempt for the
results of the elections the manifestos
were drawn up after president jaime
bolsonaro stepped up his attacks on
brazil's supreme court an electronic
voting system
in july he told a group of foreign
ambassadors that the elections could be
easily rigged
polls show bolsonaro trailing behind
former president luiz nassulullah
the movement in defense of brazil's
democracy grew over the past weeks
spreading to at least 20 state capitals
among them rio de janeiro crowds
gathered at universities here in rio and
in other cities to listen to the
manifestos being read
people here say they must show their
unity on the streets to ensure that
democracy and the rule of law prevail
manika yanakiv al-jazeera rio de janeiro